To edit your Piazza profile, click the
gear, then click Account Email Settings.
Here, you'll be able to change your name
as it appears when you post on Piazza,
as well as your preferred email
address and profile picture.
>> One thing we highly advise
is setting a profile picture.
It doesn't have to be an actual photo of
you if you aren't comfortable with that.
But simply having a unique picture
really improves your recognizability
when you're posting on Piazza.
I can say as an instructor that when I
see a name, sometimes it takes a second
to remember the conversations I've
had with that student in the past.
But when I see a picture, I usually
remember them pretty immediately.
>> Below here, you can change your
email settings for the class.
Piazza can send you a lots of emails,
depending on how you have it set up.
So if you're drowning in Piazza emails,
you can change your settings here.